thanks sarah jane and welcome to the
daily climate show here's what's coming
up for you now
no coming back a warning from the
environment agency that some communities
will need to plan their retreat from the
coast in the face of rising sea levels
fears grow for the safety of a british
environmental journalist missing in the
amazon
and insulates your homes to reduce
heating bills and emissions the head of
the cbi tells us that the government
must act now
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we report on the changes
happening to our world and hear from the
leaders who are trying to deal with
those changes and of course also hear
from the people coming up with the
solutions
now a british journalist has gone
missing in a remote part of the amazon
rainforest
dom phillips was traveling with a
brazilian expert of indigenous people
the pair had reportedly received a
number of threats from loggers and
miners in the region
mr phillips has reported in brazil for
more than 15 years and was traveling
with bruno aruja pereira he's a former
government official whose job was to
protect brazil's and contactable tribes
the pair were traveling around the
amazon rainforest near the triple border
of peru colombia and brazil
researching a book about environmental
issues
they were last seen over the weekend in
javari valley of the amazon state near
the border with peru a region which is
home to the most uncontactable
indigenous people in the world
or they set off to italia de noche by
boats on what should have been two hour
trip but never made it
the sky's leader dowd has been speaking
to don phillips sister
well in spite of don phillips living in
brazil he was very close to both his
sister and his brother in the uk they
were in direct contact all of the time
really even on the trips that he
frequently took in the amazon because
he's writing a book
currently at the moment and they've
described to me that they feel anxious
desperate worried but still hopeful that
both dom and his guide will be found but
they are concerned for their safety
dom is a freelance journalist who is
shining a light if you like on a very
politically sensitive issue in brazil
involving the struggles of the
indigenous people there
against deforestation
and
illegal logging and the family believed
there was also drug traffickers in the
area when the two disappeared as well so
they are
very concerned and
this is what sean
his sister had to tell me and she was
interviewed alongside her partner paul
he's lighting up a highlighting
spotlighting this area
and i want i want the eyes of the world
on it and i want
him and bruno to be found
yeah but our worry is that that have
been they've been abducted by somebody
who
who wanted to silence the the
the exposure that they were bringing to
illegal activities in the area
he's full of vitality i see him you know
as a he's my older brother i look up to
him i love him
dom's sister really feels that every
minute counts in this case and given
those political sensitivities with what
he was doing they don't feel like the
brazilian government is doing enough to
find the men at the moment they feel it
is only the indigenous communities
searching for them at the moment
they're not having any direct contact
with what is going on with the
authorities there and they want to see
the brazilian army brought in to try to
find the men i did ask them what contact
they'd had with british authorities and
they said that the family here in the uk
had no direct contact with them but they
hope that the british authorities will
be doing all that they can
to help
lisa dalton with those updates now on to
some of today's other climate news now
and the head of the confederation of
british industry has urged the
government to upgrade insulation and uk
homes is in a bid to reduce massive
energy bills now tony danker says around
5.2 billion pounds needs to be invested
every year until 2035 in order to
properly insulate the country's homes
which lose heat faster than anywhere
else in europe
and that could save homeowners 500
pounds a year
now heating the uk's drafty housing
stock creates about 14
of the country's carbon emissions that's
according to the committee on climate
change
some people have turned round to what's
happened with events in ukraine and
russia and said gosh you know this
proves that all that green stuff is the
wrong stuff at the wrong time it won't
help people actually the opposite is
true we've just seen fossil fuels go up
by three times where they were a year
ago we've just seen people thrown to the
mercy of global politics and war when it
comes to paying for their own energy
bills that's why we're saying today that
actually we now need to do energy
efficiency properly in this country
we've done it in other parts of the
world we've done it in other countries
in europe but we've never really
delivered it properly in the uk and you
know just getting some of our most
inefficient homes up to a basic standard
of energy efficiency would save bill
payers 500 pounds a year
a new report calls on the government to
help fund the uk's small-scale fishing
fleet switch to more sustainable engines
researchers from the university of hull
say that although technology exists for
electric or hybrid engines the current
licensing system is preventing the
uptake
the report recommends more research into
low-carbon propulsion systems and says
harbor authorities should consider
future electrification when upgrading
infrastructure
president joe biden has waived tariffs
on solar panels from four
south east asian nations for two years
it's to serve a bridge while
manufacturing in the u.s ramps up the
white house says the defense production
act
would also be used to increase
manufacturing of building insulation
heat pumps and equipment for clean
electricity generated fuels the move
comes in response to concern over a
freezing of solar projects nationwide
that's part of the administration's
plans to fight climate change
now warning from the head of the
environment agency that rising heat
levels caused by climate change will
inevitably mean some coastal communities
being forced from their homes
james bevin was speaking today at the
flood and coast conference
in the long term
climate change means that some of our
communities
both in this country and around the
world
cannot stay where they
are now that's because
while we can come back safely
and build back better
after most river flooding
there is no coming back
for land that coastal erosion has simply
taken away
or which a rising sea level
has put permanently
or frequently underwater
which means that in some places
the right answer in economic in
strategic in human terms will have to be
to move communities away
from the danger rather than to try and
protect them
from the inevitable impacts of a rising
sea
level and our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter is at
berlin gap in east sussex
it is a stark admission that despite
billions of pounds of planned spending
the government and the environment
agency can't hope to protect every
single person's home and business from
the relentless march of the ocean and
rising sea levels and increasingly
frequent increasingly severe weather
events
the environment agency does have an
extensive plan to invest in coastal
defenses and so
a large majority of people living near
the sea let's be clear about this we'll
continue to enjoy their communities but
there will be areas where that simply
isn't possible and what the environment
agency isn't saying is that all of this
change which sounds very dramatic is
going to happen tomorrow and that they
are saying that it's way too early to
predict who exactly will get to stay and
who will be forced to leave but there
are some communities uh like for example
fairborn in wales who have already been
told by the council that the flood
defenses can't be kept in place in
perpetuity
and there is going to have to be some
relocation and i think just more broadly
the news today
is a great example of how climate change
is no longer a problem for the global
south a problem for countries and
communities far far away
the impacts are here and although this
country certainly has the the
infrastructure and the means to adapt to
strengthen against
and to protect against the impacts of
climate change there is ultimately only
so much the government can do